happy Anniversary on Netflix a rom-com
starring Ben Schwartz aka jean-ralphio
from Parks and Rec Noel wells aka Zooey
Deschanel jr. this movie is more wrong
than calm it's got a very strong love
story here and this movie is all about
the little things like the key in the
gym perfume comes back around the
driveway pulling they did in the
beginning comes back at the end the
hooker roleplay Rotel room and their
memory also comes back at the end so
this is a really well thought out script
it's really tight bunched together well
it's only an hour and 18 minutes this
movie is the most up to date with the
times around comma I've seen Ben and
Noelle's characters chemistry is
excellent and they're detach from each
other just enough to make it very
realistic the comic beats in here are
great especially Ben Schwartz is friend
in this when they're trying to sell
their shirt company to the blonde lady
was probably the funniest parts in the
movie especially when she agrees to use
them the friend does an awkward
handshake attempt and then pulls back
that's the type of timing this movie was
really quick with and it worked
perfectly
and had a really clear message this
movie preaching that love is all about
risk and why it's worth it and also
preaching in love is always an
uncertainty it's never certain that felt
like a very fresh idea in the way they
presented it I even felt emotional with
the wedding scene where Noel Wells was
crying seeing the other older couple
having her anniversary I really felt it
I think it earned it they earned its
emotion at the end this was all in one
day so the stakes felt higher it really
trapped in a day what a couple would
have his drama perfectly but that's
worth to me the real realism came with
this didn't try too hard
state grounded in reality very smart for
a rom-com which is rare and was very
strong for a Netflix movie which is rare
as well this is just as good as any
rom-com you go and spend ten bucks to
see the theater the props for this movie
happening more people need to watch it
I'm gonna give it an 8.5 please
subscribe so you can check out my other
reviews I do movie reviews TV reviews
celebrity interviews you name it I'm
gonna blow you follow this movie your
quick thoughts I respond to everybody so
let's get the discussion going and I'll
see you
you